hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast by modal gene expression
in breast cancer presented by Jessica
Mar PhD dr. Marr is an assistant
professor in the department of systems
and computational biology and an
assistant professor in the Department of
Epidemiology and population health at
the Albert Einstein College of Medicine
I am Judy O'Rourke of lab routes and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box it
appears on the screen well answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble hearing or seeing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Marr I will now turn the presentation
over to her Thank You Gigi thank you so
much for the kind introduction and thank
you for to elaborate so the opportunity
to present my work at this amazing fun
virtual conference I am as Jay mentioned
an assistant professor of an Einstein
College of Medicine I also hold an
appointment at the University of
Queensland in
fannia we're I mean at the moment
building out the labs or regardless of
whatever hemisphere you're in whether
it's the northern of the southern
welcome to my presentation and please
ask as many questions as you like feel
free to reach out to me by email as well
I'd love to hear your comments on our
work so I am based in the systems
biology department at Albert Einstein
and basically what we do assistance
biologists is we try to model the
regulatory rules that are governed by
the genome in a particular cell and so
we all know that cell cellular
phenotypes are quite complicated they're
controlled not by a single gene but
actually interactions between multiple
genes and so what our job is as
biologists is really to figure out what
the wiring is of these different types
of networks that underlie a specific
phenotype and so I've used this example
with specific cells that are relate to
cancer but obviously any kind of
phenotype and here's to these kinds of
rules so you can imagine that specific
cells in our body are are controlled by
a specific regulatory network and those
networks change as the sent cell
transitions to a malignant phenotype for
instance in the case of cancer and then
again even more changes that are
occurring at the network level to become
a metastatic cell and so this process is
controlled by many different aspects
which we're trying to understand better
in order to manipulate and control
disease so we know that these networks
oh sorry
we know these networks operate with both
signal and noise and what I mean by that
is the expression or abundance of
different genes that are being produced
inside a single cell so we often think
about genes that are upregulated or
downregulated with a specific control of
baseline and this is certainly the case
what's happened in the last decade or so
is we've come to appreciate that there
is different levels of noise of these
networks also operate with and you can
imagine
with a typical signal transduction
pathway that's made up of different
regulatory molecules like receptors the
kinase Azur transcription factors that
there's a degree of variability or
heterogeneity at which these signals
that control and that can have an effect
on the degree of regulation and how much
control these networks are operating on
to define a specific phenotype so what
my lab is is really interested in
studying is this idea of heterogeneity
and how it can tell us more information
about how the genome is being controlled
and regulated and so I want to bring you
back to perhaps more high school
statistics where we're talking about the
probability density distribution so
you've probably seen this before when
you've got a ten-city curve that
represents the continuous data variable
so in this case we're going to talk
about gene expression so if you imagine
gene expression for a population of
single cells each point on this density
represents the measurement of a single
cell
for a specific gene and what is really
interesting is that the shape of that
particular distribution tells us a lot
of information about that particular
genes role in in a population so in
bioinformatics and in a lot of
statistical modeling in genomics we
often focus on the main or the median
which is basically the central location
of this density and in statistics we
refer to that as the first moment but in
actual fact there are other moments or
other summary measures that can define
properties of this distribution Sir
Francis the second moment you may be
familiar with which is the variance and
this this catches the width of this
distribution and we can keep going to
higher moments that really tell us
different aspects of this distribution
so for instance the third moment is
skewness this reflects how asymmetric a
distribution is and we can keep going up
further so ketosis hyper skewness and as
we get higher into these moments they
lose some of their interpretive ability
but the point is that there
our different properties of
distributions based on their shapes and
in fact some of these higher moments can
be really helpful for understanding how
these shapes are distributed and I think
what we're really missing out on in
bioinformatics is that we're focusing
only on that first moment so there's a
lot more information to be mined from
the gene expression distribution itself
and one feature which will be the theme
of this talk is the idea of by modality
where this this distribution looks
completely different from the
stereotypical when I represented here in
the fact that there are two modes and
and not one but before we get to that I
just want to bring bring this back in
terms of the idea of looking at changes
in distribution as a way to understand
regulation in the genome in genomics we
also look at genes that are
differentially expressed and a statistic
that we often use to do this is the
familiar t-test so if you go back to
your high school math the the t-test is
is a statistic that's composed of
looking at differences in average
expression and if we take the example of
a disease group and a control group so
two sample t-test you can see that genes
have an average a largest separation in
their distributions are gonna be
prioritized by the teachers a statistic
and then we often balance the statistic
by dividing by some sort of measure of
noise so what this actually says is that
we want genes that are highly separated
in terms of the average expression with
quite reliable or minimal noise in each
of those distributions and this is a
very insightful way to characterize
changes between the two transcriptomes
in in phenotypes that we're interested
in studying both scenarios where this
the t-test is not taking differences
into account our Illustrated below the
gray line so there's one example where
for instance there is separation between
the disease group and the control group
but as you can see by
the green and blue lines the variability
in the disease group for this particular
cotton gene is much wider than the
variability and expression for the
control group so perhaps that could
indicate some sort of upstream mutation
or aspect of that particular disease
that is causing increased variability in
the expression of that gene and on the
right of the slide we have a more
extreme example where in fact there is
no separation in terms of the average
expression two distributions between
disease and control completely overlap
each other but in fact you can see that
this considerable spread that's
different between the disease and
control and so this very simple idea is
one that we exploited in the context of
a factor a stem cells looking at
neurological disorders like
schizophrenia and Parkinson's disease
and so I invite you to check out a paper
that we wrote quite a while ago in PLoS
genetics that took this idea and ran
with it to really understand what other
genes work attempt in these particular
diseases but I want to focus more on
this issue of by modality and bring the
idea back to the fact that when we look
at gene expression data there are a lot
of different kinds of distributions that
can theoretically be present right so we
often think of the normal distribution
on this bell curve distribution which
makes a lot of sense for continuous data
but on statistics we know that there are
actually other distributions that we can
use to represent continuous data and so
some of these include the Cauchy
distribution which is like the normal
but has higher tails Ezell said the log
normal which is completely skewed the
Pareto distribution which is heavily
skewed as a spiky point their extreme
values the gamma distribution which
looks skewed here with a heavy tail but
can actually adopt a variety of
different shapes and finally the bimodal
distribution which is unique in the
sense that there are two modes in this
distribution instead of one so one thing
that we set out today a few years ago
was to really test this question of
whether not
normal distributions existed in human
cancer transcriptomes
we know in theory that there are
different distributions but the question
really was do they exist in in real data
and so what we used in this particular
case was data from the Casa genome atlas
which many of you may be familiar with
it's a wonderful resource out there and
we selected three different tumor types
acute myeloid leukemia glioblastoma and
ovarian cancer and these come with
really quite large sets of patient
cohort data we took all level 3 data and
we basically asked this question of
which distribution shapes were present
in both RNA seek and microarray data
from these 3 tumor types and this was
work that was led by my postdoc doctor
laurels to Toronto and my program is Sam
cinnamon they constructed a
classification pipeline to basically
identify which genes had expression
profiles that fit into these different
shapes and so you can see that there's a
series of flowcharts here that implement
the different or describe the the
different tests we use to implement
these decisions no gene was forced into
one distribution and in fact if it
didn't seem likely that they fit into
any distributions it was discarded from
the analysis so from this what we found
was a considerable proportion of the
cancer transcriptome is actually non
normal and that was a really interesting
surprising result for us you can see by
the buckshots
on the left we have data from the marker
a data on the right we have the RNA seek
data and the same tumors are represented
what we wanted to show was that these
distributions were in fact not specific
to a platform and you can see while the
counts that are a little bit different
it's so quite interesting to say that
the different no normal distributions
are representing reasonable chunks here
here of the transcriptome so one thing
that really
cut-out I which we followed up on and
we'll talk about today is the fact that
genes that work by mortal were quite
significantly represented here and these
represent the blue panels that you see
in in the bar chart so we wanted to
follow up on this particular result
because there's a lot of interest or
implications if you like but bimodal
gene expression and just to unpack that
idea a little bit more carefully
if we focus then on on a bimodal shape
what this actually means is that for a
patient cohort a subset of tumors from
these patients are expressing a specific
gene at a higher level and the remaining
cohort so this actually creates a
division if you like in the patient
population that indicates there's a
differential expression component
occurring here but it's one we wouldn't
find readily or easily without more
traditional tools like looking at
differential expression so this really
begs the question for how many how many
genes that we missing how many
interesting aspects about biology are we
not finding because we're not looking at
non normal distribution specifically by
Mertle gene profiles so this is a
project that one of my PhD students
Daniel pique really wanted to dig into
and he was particularly interested in
breast cancer so what we did was we
applied this idea of looking at bimodal
genes in a TCGA breast cancer cohort and
bimodal distributions this is not
something that is novel on you in the
statistical modeling world and in fact
what we can do is we can use mixture
models to actually model these
distributions and basically what that
means is we can fit a model that looks
for these two representations and it
fits these different parameters that we
can actually estimate properties about
these two distributions and that gives
us more information about first of all
evaluating whether it's likely that this
particular
gene expression profile is bimodal a
distributed as opposed to any modal or
some other distribution and then once we
have that we have these parameters that
we can extrapolate back to describe the
underlying patient populations so for
instance in this diagram I have these
two parameters me1 me2 that reflects the
expression of the gene in these two
modes and what's perhaps more relevant
of these pi this PI parameter so pi
represents the proportion of patients
are in that lower mode or mode 1 + 1 -
pi because we have two modes 1 minus PI
represents the the population that's
left over that's expressing that higher
mode the second mode so we took some of
these ideas that have been published
before one notable publication is in
tongue in bioinformatics published in
2013 and we really wanted to look for
whether these bimodal express genes were
present in the breast cancer dataset and
so this is one example that we pulled
out where you can see when you overlay
the RNA seek data here we use transcript
per million counts you can see that
there's actually really convincing
bimodal separation for this particular
breast cancer population so this gave us
some hope and sort of opened the door in
terms of finding about finding out more
information about tumor biology through
this particular lens so one aspect of
breast cancer and and all cancers is
this idea of oncogenes and so oncogenes
are genes that are highly expressed in
the instruments that drive the
proliferation and other cat's cancer
related properties of these particular
samples so one aspect of the Cancer
Genome Atlas is that in many of the
tumors there's for every tumor sample
that's been profiled there's an adjacent
normal tissue from the same patient and
so this gives us an enormous opportunity
to
contrast genes expression profile
between these two datasets as a way to
identify oncogene and so bringing in
this component of by modality the way we
wanted to use this specifically was to
identify bimodal expression in the tumor
of tumor samples that wasn't present in
the adjacent normal and specifically
what we wanted to see was the
disappearance of that higher express
mode in the tumor sample so you can see
in this red and blue a series of
densities here the idea is that for a
particular gene it's highly expressed in
a subset of tumors that's the green of
the blue profile to the right but when
we look at the same gene in the adjacent
normal group all we see is the low
express mode and it's unimodal so this
disappearance of that second mode
suggests that for this particular subset
of patients it's over expressing this
particular gene that's not present in
normal humans at normal samples sorry so
this is what we what we mean by a
theoretical on coaching candidate it's
this idea that this particular cartoon
or stereotyped behavior is what we want
to detect to see if genes fit this
profile in the breast cancer data set
and if so what is it that those genes in
doing so basically as I said we came out
with this particular theoretical model
and then applied it to the Casa genome
sorry chance to Gina gene Alice data so
what we did specifically then oh sorry
to just step back and and motivate this
a little bit more I think well we do
understand a lot of a lot of different
oncogenes currently I think there is a
drive to discover new oncogenes because
this would give us ways to develop new
therapeutic strategies and I think
you're free step through and consider
what are some of the properties that are
really desirable for oncogene
when we're looking for them in data is
that obviously their overexpressed in a
subset of tumors right and we know that
these particular oncogenes promote tumor
growth what makes it attractive as a
particular potential therapeutic
strategy is the fact that this anchor
gene is not expressed in healthy animal
tissue and that's the reason for that is
that we want to reduce side effects
rights for any sort of protective
potential strategy so if that's highly
targeted towards the tumor cell then
that improves the efficiency of the
therapy ideally also these oncogenes are
expressed in tumors with poor prognosis
so that will improve overall ability to
cure cancer to control cancer in old
patients not just the ones that we have
good reliable there are therapies for
and then obviously to take this to the
next level the oncogene really has to
have a targetable domain that we can
manipulate so these are just some of the
reasons which motivated our study to use
these kinds of ideas to identify new
oncogenes and the way we actually
implemented this was through a series of
steps at the beginning starting with RNA
seek data that was downloaded from TCGA
they this table represents some of the
characteristics that are like the
patient population that we were working
with the numbers were initially about
100 to minimal pairs from the same
patients and then through a series of
different pre-processing steps to ensure
quality and stability of our models we
whittle down the number of available
mRNAs that were you know analysis down
to about for a less than 4000 and what
we did was in addition to filtering as I
said for the quality we imposed a series
of different statistics to identify the
bimodal eg expressed genes and I'm gonna
go through some of that right now
so the idea underlying was
obviously was to fit a Gaussian to
component mixture model suppose the
tumor and adjacent normal gene
expression profiles and in the process
of trying to determine ways to then
understand whether genes were expressed
according to a bimodal profile we
developed a metric called the
selectivity index and basically what
this does is it takes the parameters
that was fitted or the estimates that
were fitted from a mixture model to
evaluate whether there's enough clean
separation in the group of tumors that
were larger expressing a particular gene
so basically the selectivity index works
off the tumor bimodal expression profile
and the adjacent normal expression
profile and here on the right we've got
two examples of profiles of genes with
high and low selectivity indices this
index goes from 0 to 1 so it gives you
an idea of how how graphically this
index is operating so for the high
selectivity index where it's 1 you can
see that there's a clean separation in
terms of the tumor some Girt that's
overexpressing which you can see in in
blue it's on the on the right hand side
that that subgroup is really far away
from both the low mode but also the red
red distribution of which reflects the
expression in the adjacent normal group
if we contrast that to a gene that has a
low selectivity index you can see that
the densities are really quite
overlapping in terms of what we see for
the adjacent normal so that's really not
reflective of what would be an
interesting or sort of valuable gene to
follow up in terms of our investigation
of by modality so we use this index to
separate out the candidates we had for
consideration and basically our
objective was to use the selectivity
index first
pulled with a non-chemical which I'll
explain in a little bit to identify
ultimately this profiles cartoon at the
top right hand side of the slide so
basically can we computationally
identify genes that followed this
particular expression pattern so using
the selectivity index that allowed us to
rank genes that were worthwhile to
filter it to the next stage we use the
cutoff that was quite stringent of 0.99
in terms of the selectivity index that
gave us 139 candidates work with from
that 139 we then used an uncracked score
which basically looks at the separation
between the expression of the two modes
with the tightness which that expression
is being distributed in the adjacent
normal and treatment groups so basically
we took the top 5 of these particular
automix genes
okay mixed score genes and that's what
you see here on the the right hand side
of the panel these were the size genes
that were in our top five ranking
according to their own Comex for and we
will let me go into that a little bit
more in a little bit more detail so
we've taken these top 5 as candidates to
study further in terms of their Oncotype
okay gene candidate sort of abilities
and what is shown here is a table with
the gene symbols and also they're known
functions according to NCBI there are
two genes here which have prior roles
associated with anchor Genesis and
that's an l2 and another gene CB x2
which will focus on more in this talk
the question is obviously when you
develop a new bioinformatics method is
how well does it do compared to existing
approaches and so we looked at that
question by using two different methods
we used limo which is one of the most
common methods that use to analyze gene
expression data
it's often used to look for
differentially expressed genes and as
you can see when you do look at
differential expression there really
there really isn't a lot of overlap in
terms of the ranking or prioritization
that lemma has with alchemic so you can
see what we've done is we've shown the
rank out of the nearly 8,000 genes that
was statistically significant in terms
of their upregulation and you can see
that those ranks for Limor for for the
genes that we've identified Cerrone
comics are no 1 year you know the top 5
the other method that we used was m-kopa
and this is a method that looks at
outliers what we're trying to do by
looking at the bimodal expression and
specifically contrasting with the
adjacent normal is akin somewhat to
looking at outlier outlier samples on
outlier tumors so we used uncarpeted to
see if we could pick up any of the genes
that we had identified with on cream mix
and you can say that that though this
wasn't the case at all there was an
overlap in what M croaker was finding as
far as it considered genes that were
determining these particular outliers so
we were quite encouraged with the
exclusivity that we saw in the top 5
genes that were ranked by on commits and
the gene CB x2 was a gene that we were
quite interested for its role in the
polycomb complex but also its high rank
so what we did was we decided to delve
into this further and we looked at genes
that were differentially expressed
between tumors that were over expressing
CBS 2 so now we're using CB X 2 as a
classification for tumors in the TCGA
data set so we used it to classify these
tumors into two groups
basically those that were expressed
things you can extrude and those that
were not and then between those two
groups we identified genes that were
differentially expressed so this is a
volcano plot
showing results of that differential
expression analysis and what you see
which was quite interesting is an
enrichment of pathways that were related
to the cell cycle
so we've labeled some of those genes
that are known to be involved here they
relate to the GTM checkpoint in the cell
cycle and what's interesting for CBS two
is that this is really quite consistent
with some of the the poss work that's
been done to understand the function of
CB X 2 and the contribution of this gene
to cancer so in a past study that was
done in 2014
CB x tree was knocked out using SI RNA
in prostate cancer cells so that's quite
different from breast cancer cells but
it was interesting to note that genes
that would differentiable also enriched
for the cell cycle related pathways so
this result is consistent with what
we're seeing with us we took the same
kind of analysis where we use the
oncogene candidate as a way to classify
the patient samples into the two groups
and we looked at genes that were
differentially expressed and
specifically what pathways were over
enriched in those genes and so this
table represents for the five oncogenes
candidates that we found what some of
those enrichment results was were that
was statistically significant you can
see that not all oncogene candidates
were represented um that's due to the
fact that some of those some of it
didn't have a statistically significant
enrichment perhaps owing to a lower
number of different shapes for us teens
but it's interesting to note that these
pathways are related as you might expect
two cell cycle to proliferation type
processes that that would be that would
make sense for these particular Chua's
so what we also wanted to do was that
given this bimodal profile we wanted to
post the question of what other sorts of
regulatory or underlying molecular
features are actually defining the
segregate
of these tumors into one mode versus
another so for instance could we use
information from DNA methylation or
information from genetic variation to
define or predict which tumor is more
likely to go into the low expression
mode or the high expression mode of the
particular okay okay gene candidate so
to do that you can imagine that is a
huge exercise in data education and
statistical modeling so what we used for
this particular problem is a method
called lasso and this is a variable
selection method that uses logistic
regression and essentially it allows for
the inclusion of lots of different
coefficients or covariance and it
shrinks the weights that these
coefficients through feature selection
to ensure representation of these
covariance and predicting the final
outcome and so al final outcome of
interest yeah was to use the membership
of a particular tumor in the higher mode
or the lower mode depending on the angka
gene candidate so I apologize for the
animation here is a little bit sketchy
but essentially this this reflects the
steps that we used to implement less so
for this particular data integration
analysis the package that was used was
GLM net and the code is available so
please feel free to contact us if you'd
like to see how we did this
implementation so basically this is the
result of our multi omec prediction
basically we combine lots of different
variables that were available in TCGA
for this particular set of patients and
these can be broken down into various
different categories you can see on the
panel on panel a on the left the the
first category related to GN a CPG
methylation so what we wanted
to do was include the influence from DNA
methylation of CPG sites that were in
proximity to this particular antigen
candidate right so these were broken
down into specific regions the promoter
the exons the introns the other category
we wanted to include was those related
to gene expression and copy number
variation so for instance we used
classification molecular subtyping tool
called aims which I'll go into in a few
slides time we wanted to include also
copy number variation of that particular
gene in case that was an influencing
factor you can imagine that higher copy
number may relate to a higher gene
expression of that particular gene we
also have expression in the normal
tissue so that's that's a component
because in this case we're modeling for
our lasso model we're using the tumor
data directly but we also wanted to
factor in expression in the normal
tissue as well there are also very
relevant covariates to include that come
from clinical data and obviously there
are aspects that pathologists have have
looked at for instance like the stage of
the tumor a percentage of tumor cells
and also things like race and age that
also we know play a role in the
particular tumor we also wanted to
include technical variables and while
these may not be so exciting to study
from a biological perspective the subtly
important in adjusting for if we're
going to have after an estimate student
other factors and so these are things
like the sequencing plate or the
hospital that these samples were
profiled
patients where the patients were these
are all factors that we hope don't have
a huge influence but by putting them
into the model we're able to
quantitatively adjust for them and
account for their influence so we know
for sure which is the best way to go so
we used this lesson model to
individually fit this multi omec model
for each
Kouji candidates and at the top of the
panel you can see that we've got area
under the curve values that represent
the the fit or the appropriateness of
this particular model for the different
oncogene candidates and you can see
that's a range of values CB x2 has the
highest AUC value zero point eight nine
basically the way these values work is
if it's 0.5 it's basically a random
random prediction random guess and so
the closer to 1 the more confident that
this is a predictive model it is so
point a 9 is is really great it gives us
a lot of confidence in this model and
the other thing to note is the
coefficient rankings so you'll see for
CB x2 for instance one two and three
that have been highlighted in blue the
ranking represents the significance of
this covariant in predicting the overall
assignment of whether a tumor is likely
to being that high expression mode or
the lowest freshman part and the color
of the intensity of that color
represents the direction of that
prediction so for instance a covariate
could positively influence or negatively
influence that particular prediction so
you can see that these different
predictions are old negative in terms of
that molecule efficient and one of the
the most the most significant covariant
is DNA DNA methylation specifically in
the intron ik region so on the right
hand panel on the panel B what we've got
on the DNA methylation data values these
are values that go from 0 to 1 Azura
represents not methylated one represents
fully methylated and you can see the
individual values for the patients that
had baseline cbx to expression versus
those that were very first so these are
the guys who were in the lower and the
higher expression modes and you can see
that really there is quite a striking
difference in the distribution of these
this this particular covariant between
these two groups and so it's really not
a surprise that this particular variate
was the highest had the highest rank or
the highest weight towards determining
that prediction and when you do wilcoxon
rank-sum test between these two groups
you see that that that differences is
highly significant
so another result that we wanted to dig
in more deeply was to understand how CPG
methylation was distributed across this
particular CB extreme gene okay and this
is something that we were able to
extrapolate from from the lasso model
and you can see in this top panel
there's box plots that sure what's going
on in terms of these DNA methylation
beta values in the CB x to baseline
buzzes the overexpress script so this is
the low and the high mode expression and
you can see at different locations as we
step from upstream of the transcription
side all the way down to the last exon
that region you can see that there are a
different changes occurring between
these two groups of humans what we did
was because we're looking at breast
cancer we were able to integrate this
data using the MCS seventh cell line
which was profiled extensively answering
the encode project the OCS seven cell
line is a breast cancer cell line it was
originally derived from a Caucasian
elderly patient who had luminal a breast
cancer and so this actually represents a
really good fit to our cohort in terms
of those demographics so it's I think a
valuable resource to be looking at
changes that we observed in our data so
what we did was we used transcription
factor binding and histone chips each
track data that was downloaded from mcf7
they have a foot from the encode project
they have a lot of different tracks
available so we took 66 of these and
look four hours elapsed with the CPG
like a
and that we observed in our data and
that's what's shown here with these
black boxes the black boxes represent an
overlap between the binding site region
from encode for those mcf-7 cells and
also with the data that we observed from
TCGA and so it's interesting to note is
that you see representation between
these two sets for a lot of different
kinds of of mobs and so what's really
interesting that we thought was the
transcription factor Jun D so Jun D is a
transcription factor that's well known
for promoting and cell proliferation and
cancer and what you see is that there's
an overlap in the binding site for june
d as well as a host of other enhancer
promoter repressive marks from encode
and this this overlaps with the second
intron for CB x2 so that's quite
interesting and so that allowed us to
propose a potential mechanism at least
hypothetically in terms of how Jin D and
C bx2 are coming together to drive this
over expression that we're observing in
the breast tumors so in normal tissue
what we see perhaps we see is this this
lack of migration or coming of June D to
bind to this site where in humans that
are overexpressed we see this this
binding allow for the over expression of
this particular gene and this gene of
the transcription factors is binding
around the second intron area and so
this is a hypothetical mask mechanism it
remains to be validated but that's
certainly something that we so
consistently from from our data and in
terms of validation I'll come back to
that in a few slides time in terms of
understanding sleeping it's two more in
our patient population what we also saw
was that using CB x2 to segregate the
two sets of tumors also results
in a difference in survival rates so for
instance patients that were in that
higher mode of expression they had over
expression of CB x2
they had a different rate of survival
from those baseline patients and so you
can see that according to a log rank
test this this difference was
statistically significant and so it's
interesting to note that over expression
of this particular on catching candidate
is associated with lower rates of
survival in these patients the other
thing we wanted to know it was looking
at how aggressive these tumors were and
whether there was any correlation or
Association with CBS 2 expression and so
here what we used was a classifier
called Ames
this stands for absolute assignment of
breast cancer intrinsic molecular
subtype and basically what Ames does is
it's a signature that's used to classify
humans into these different molecular
subtypes and so that's what you see in
this this Bob point here where we have
the normal we have liminal a B co2 and
basal subtypes and so Ames is made up of
a set of different genes but it's
interesting to note that CB x 2.is is
not one of them and when you look at the
you rank these tumors types in terms of
tumor aggressiveness
there is actually a correlation with the
percentage of patients that were in that
overexpression CBS 2 group and so you
can see that with the presentative
analyst at the top of the bachata but
also by looking at the height of the
dark blue bar so you can see that as
you're employed a high tumor
aggressiveness the ink the more more of
those subtypes are reflecting patients
that were in that over expression of CBS
2 group so this is just that perhaps CBS
2 you might have some utility in
identifying or even subtyping aggressive
breast tumors that's something we'd like
to follow up on in in more detail later
as I said
the beginning of my presentation a
valuable oncogene is one that is not
highly expressed in normal adult tissue
and that's the reason for ensuring a
lack of side effects and an increasing
specificity of the therapeutic target so
what we did was we use gtex data so this
is normal tissue that's been profiled
it's a huge resource so there are there
are about 500 human joiners that have
given rise to this data set and there's
a panel of 53 different tissues so
there's something like nearly 9,000
individual samples that would derive
from these eight hundred five hundred
excuse me also donors to devices amazing
data set so what we did was we looked at
the expression of CB X 2 in this
particular cohort and we saw that for
the most part the expression of CB x
2.is is very low if not non-existent for
this particular tissue panel what's
really interesting though as you can see
there's this boss foot to the right that
is highly expressed and this actually
corresponds to that adult testes group
and so it's interesting to know it given
that the way that we've been studying CB
x 2 is in the context of breast cancer
where we're looking exclusively at
female patients so this is encouraging
it's a con it's encouraging to see that
CB x 2.is is not widely expressed across
multiple two tissues and that also the
expression of CB x 2.is is quite low if
not not expressed at all so these are
all computational predictions that I've
told you about today that tie into CB x
2 and its relevance as an oncogene
candidate for breast cancer obviously
the strength of computational
predictions are really great but limited
somewhat in terms of making a concrete
statements about biology so what we
wanted to do was really go into the lab
and experimentally validate CB x to
now there are various various different
ways that you can validate a particular
gene what we decided to do in this case
was to look again within the mcf-7 cell
line and knock down CB x - i'm using SI
RNA and so what we did was we did a time
course experiment where we looked at the
expression of CB x 2 we also looked at
these cell counts or the growth of these
cells in this population both with the
SI RNA knockdown and also in that inner
control group and so when we looked at
it here in cells in the mcf-7 line over
a week-long period we saw that there was
a significant reduction in the growth of
these cells in the presence of the CB x
to knock out knock down excuse me so we
we arrived to that result using a three
way ANOVA we were accounting for the SI
RNA status so whether whether the the
knockdown was present or we were looking
at the control sample we also included
the temporal component so the fact that
this was conducted over multiple days
and then we were also fortunate enough
to have three replicates for each each
time point and each experiment so the
control and the CB x to knockdown and so
overall we see that there is a
significant difference even though that
might be harder to just send from the
actual cluster of points but that
certainly gives us confidence that in
the mcf7 cells we do see an effect of
these cancer cells and in their ability
to grow in the same way as the control
group so obviously there's many other
stages of validation that remains to be
done but certainly this gives us a lot
of hope and excitement that our
computational predictions validate at
this level so what I wanted to do is
just summarize the findings of our
results we've used this idea of looking
at by mortally
fresh jeans to understand more about
breast cancer specifically to find
oncogene candidates that we may have
missed through relying on more
traditional approaches like differential
expression we've identified five
oncogene candidates from this particular
analysis they are clearly order
expressed in a subset of humans which is
quite exciting because what we've done
here has been able to identify a subset
of tumors so this is almost a
personalized medicine type approach
where these oncogenes are overexpressed
only in this subset of cubans but not in
others so it would normally be quite
difficult to discover these genes when
we look for gist disease versus control
type analyses it's quite promising in
terms of the potential mechanism in
which CB x 2 is being over expressed we
hypothesize that comes about through
intronic CPG methylation and the
interaction with the transcription
factor should be it's interesting when
we look at the ability of sleeping x 2
to influence tumor growth we slow
without SI RNA knockdown in the mcf7
cells that breast cancer cell growth was
disrupted been slowed down and so also
coupling them with the early effect that
we saw with the influence of cell cycle
genes that were associated with the
tumors that had apparition of CB x 2 and
then finally coupled with the the
observation that CB x 2 is expressed at
very low levels in most healthy adults
issues and with exception to adult
testes the other thing I wanted to
highlight is that this method on Co
mix-ins packaged up in bioconductor
package so it's freely available it's
publicly accessible and you can download
it right now from the link at the bottom
of the slide
we'd love her any feedback or ideas or
questions in terms of how to use this
software
and also even in extending out we would
love to collaborate with people who
might have an interest in that
particular area so I'd like to close my
presentation by acknowledging the many
people who have helped support our lab
and and collaborated with us and been
part of this this work my lab at
Einstein contains many amazing people
specifically I wanted to acknowledge
Daniel pk who's the student that drove
this particular project by mobile
expression Lawrence and Sam worked on
the earlier pod in terms of looking at
the influence of different distribution
and we've had many amazing summit
students as well come join the lab and
they've each contributed different pots
we work with collaborators both locally
and Einstein through young business lab
Jahnke really we also collaborate with
people at chop and in Australia where
I'm looking to recruit people so if
you're interested in opportunities in
Australia please get in touch I like to
make our funding sources as well that
have supported at work so I will end
there and take any questions thank you
so much for your attention as well thank
you dr. Marr for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click the send button
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for so let's get started
our first question is the angka mix
method is built around the concept of
detecting bimodal expression profiles
would it be possible to extend this
method to look for trimodal
or multimodal profiles - yes absolutely
sorry the idea of looking at different
modes is is not exclusive to by modality
and in fact you can extend your mixture
model to specify as many
as make what makes sense to you so I
think in this case it would be really
interesting to look third try Moodle or
even more modes in the context of the
breast cancer data I think it would be
interesting to contrast that still with
a unimodal expression in the adjacent
normal group but that might give you an
ability to look at gene expression
levels then in a more of a discrete so
the categorical way so for instance if
you had a tri modal distribution perhaps
that intermediate mode which is
basically sort of so you have like 1
mode 2 mode 3 mode so that intermediate
mode may have clinical significance but
for instance when we were looking at
tumor aggressiveness perhaps there is
somewhat of a dosage effect associated
with the expression of that particular
gene so having a trimodal distribution
would allow you to identify and classify
those tumors that were falling into
those three groups and look perhaps the
contrasting properties that were
specifically the intermediate group was
specific to the most highly expressed
group in the same way that that we've
been doing with bimodal expression so I
think there may be certain certain genes
for which that particular kind of
question might be more appropriate or
more interesting to model so if anyone
out there has them some other ideas
perhaps associated with specific
oncogenes that are associated with you
know genetic mutations or downstream you
know protein expression that would be a
really cool test case to try that idea
out thank you for that when constructing
the multi omec prediction for each
anchor gene candidate using lasso it
seemed that for CB x - the prediction
was very good for other oncogene
candidates oh but for other oncogene
candidates the performance was poorer
how do you interpret this result and is
the model inappropriate or is it the
gene it's
yeah that's a good question I think when
we're always working with high
dimensional data it's always a challenge
to know when we're using too much data
or just the right amount of data or the
specific data variables that result in
that a good prediction and I think
that's something we wrestle with a lot
in genomics if you look at the a you see
values they came out of the last time
model I think one of the reasons perhaps
why some of the oncogene candidates
performed well poorly is perhaps the the
set of predictors or the set of
covariance that were input into the
model so it's possible that for instance
um a pyc that was the gene that had an
atc of 0.5 it's possible that the set of
covariance that we use to do that
prediction were not sufficient so
whether it was that those we needed to
add other introduced other kinds of
covariance it's always a trade-off
between you know which cover it's you
include versus how many so at the same
time you don't want to swamp the model
even though that is something that less
though is optimized to help do but in
terms of just interpretability as well
like how many car variants that are
really helpful to include here so it's
possible that you know for this
particular Gina a different set or a
more expansive set that covered other
attributes may be more helpful in which
case that suggests the model is not as
appropriate as the one that we tried
alternatively it could also be a gene
that doesn't lend itself to prediction
of these particular variants and that's
something that we would need to delve
into more more deeply to understand
which of those scenarios or our answers
it actually is thank you we have time
for one more question
are there other applications that uncle
mix could be used for possibly not
involving cancer yes sir as I mentioned
this this idea of bimodal expression is
is really quite intuitive
straight forward so it is definitely
applicable to other situations that
don't necessarily involve Juma's the
idea or the idea that's critical I think
to the comparison is this idea of
contrasting between two groups so if you
have a disease group and a control group
or a drug a group and a drug beat group
this kind of idea would be entirely
applicable what we're looking for is
differences in those distributions so
whether you see two two modes a bimodal
profile that shrinks down to one mode in
one group versus another that's
something that one can mix does really
well so it's not tied to despite the
name it's not tied to cancer related
applications and I think it's worth
pointing out too that although we've
done this in the context of a patient
cohort where we're looking at primary
tumors there's no reason why we can't
look at populations of other things so I
think most excitingly looking at single
cell type questions or datasets would be
really really cool
because now you've got a population of
single cells that are presumably in most
cases isogenic you're also doing have to
be but if you're dealing with isogenic
cells and it would be really interesting
to look at the distribution of a
particular gene in that single cell
population and look for the
disappearance or appearance of different
modes and in fact we could modify our
mix to perhaps look for the appearance
of bimodal expression in one group buses
and other not necessarily anchored
around a control group in the past we
have looked at some case studies of
multi modality in single cell data and I
think they're because we're dealing with
single cells we see many modes and that
makes sense because we expect to see
different subcategories of
transcriptions within these cells so I
think modeling that more directly using
mixture models would be really really
interesting and then to bring in the
any prediction if that data was
available would be quite quite
interesting to use if anyone has ideas
of that or has further questions and
please please drop me an email or use
assistance available with lab rates we'd
love to hear from you thank you for that
I would like to once again thank dr. Mar
for her presentation I would also like
to thank lab roots for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through August 10th
2018 you'll receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
will be available for replay please
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that is all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon bye